the public education foundation unites
the community to inspire support of our
public schools and they have a fun way
for all of us to help them continue
their mission here to tell us more from
the public education foundation
president kirsten sarah welcome thank
you so much i love what you guys do for
our public schools tell everyone a
little bit about the public education
foundation what you guys do
well we all knew that our schools need
support from our community but i think a
lot of times people don't know how to
provide that support right and so what
we do is we provide a way for businesses
or even the everyday person to provide
support that they know will be directed
in the right direction for our kids and
for our schools now what kind of support
do you provide to the schools well this
year we gave out five million dollars in
college scholarships wow
yes oh my goodness that's amazing and
we're really proud that more than half
of our recipients are the first in their
family to go to college so we work
really hard to make sure that we're
targeting all of our students and
telling every student they have an
opportunity
to go to college if that's their dream
and so we also have a super store for
teachers where they can get low-cost
school supplies did you know the average
teacher spends more than 500 of their
own money on school supplies every year
that is absolutely ridiculous
and for you guys to be there to help
them fund that that's that's pretty
incredible you guys do so much thank you
now this money doesn't just fall from
the air
we really need support from people and
viewers like you and you're doing
you're getting some funds raised this
coming september 9th tell us a little
bit about what's going on so we are
having our golden apple gala and you
know a lot of these galas you end up
honoring folks from the community which
is great but we said this is a time when
we really need to honor our educators we
want to have a red carpet event for our
educators so we just last week surprised
the ccsd teacher of the year principal
of the year support professional of the
year central administrator of the year
they are going to be our honorees and
the people who we really shine the light
on at this event i well deserve to and
this is not just your ordinary event
this is the golden apple gala so you
really are taking it up a notch tell us
where is it what's going on and how do
we be a part of this well we're going to
be at the caesars palace pools i think
you've got some footage of how beautiful
it is we've got student performers
it's really a party it's not a long
program we're going to honor our
educators but it's really a party to
celebrate our educators and to enjoy the
community
coming together to say that we think
it's important to invest in our public
schools it's really at a beautiful venue
there at caesars palace too if people
want to go how do they get tickets well
there's all sorts of ways that folks can
support pef at the pef.org
there are tickets still available for
the golden apple gala but we have other
opportunities too lots of people sponsor
scholarships lots of people sponsor
teachers for our teacher superstore you
can do that for you can sponsor a
teacher for twenty six dollars and then
do you just go to your website to do
that that's the pef.org okay and the
golden apple gala is gonna be fantastic
because i hear you've got the best mc in
town well we do have kendall tenney
kendall tenney is going to be emceeing
so you know you want to go that sounds
like an incredible event thank you for
what you guys do for our students in our
public schools it is really really
important work and for really
recognizing our educators that's really
special so thank you so much kirsten
great to have you here thank you to the
public education foundation for
sponsoring this segment the golden apple
gala it's happening september 9th at
caesar's palace and if you want more
information you can go to
thepef.org we will be